my name is Joel mang I'm a current
junior from Cleveland Ohio studying
journalism and American Studies I'm a
proud member of Delta Tau Delta
fraternity and compete on hills dales
forensics team it is my honor to
introduce the speaker this evening dr.
Charles Kessler is the dangler dike my
distinguished professor of government at
Claremont McKenna College where his
students have called him compelling
interesting and the best professor at
CMC he is a senior fellow at the
Claremont Institute editor of the
Claremont Review of Books instructor for
the Claremont Institute's publius
fellows and Lincoln fellows programs and
host of the claremont video series the
american mind dr. Kessler is a recipient
of the 2018 Bradley prize which honors
those who have been influential in
American debate and scholarly work he is
the author of I am the change Barack
Obama on the crisis of liberalism an
editor of several books including the
Federalist Papers which some of you may
have read dr. Kessler earned his
bachelor's degree in social studies and
his master's and Doctorate degrees in
government from Harvard University
please join me in welcoming dr. Charles
Kesler
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
I'm grateful to Joel for that eloquent
introduction I had no idea he was so
dangerous to be a member of the fencing
team or was it forensics well what one
of those whatever it was no Joel is
stalking me because he's in my class you
know as a Pulliam fellow you're supposed
to teach a class and I am and he's one
of the 10 students in that class and
then John Miller my immediate host here
at Hillsdale had me sit in on one of his
classes on Tuesday and there was Joel in
the class then John had me sit in on
another one of his classes today
there was Joel in the class as you can
tell the John does not had a heavy
teaching schedule this week but I see
Joel everywhere I go and I'm delighted
to do so he's a very smart young man and
I must I will report that the 10
students in the Pulliam seminar I'm
teaching are learning witty and there's
no trouble in getting a discussion going
the only trouble is stopping the
discussion at the end
but Thank You Joel for that very
generous introduction I'm here tonight
as the latest in a long series of
distinguished Pulliam lecturers and I'm
grateful to the Pulliam journalism
foundation and - Doug Jeffrey the vice
president of External Relations and to
Professor Miller who together administer
the pullian program here at Hillsdale
I'm especially grateful to president
Larry Arne he and I have been
for almost 40 years
back then he's oh he's right here Larry
Arne have you ever met him it's a very
nice fella back back then we would never
have believed we could be so old but now
looking back it's hard to believe we
were ever so young but through it all I
have treasured my friendship with Larry
and his beautiful wife penny who's also
here tonight I've had to listen to a lot
of Churchill's stories but really are
there any better stories you know so I
feel I feel enlightened American
politics today are not nearly so
inspiring as those scenes from
Churchill's life obnoxious gangs accost
the president's press secretary and a
u.s. senator trying to have dinner with
their families in Washington DC forcing
them to flee on campuses across the
country not Hillsdale conservative
speakers are shouted down or otherwise
prevented from speaking a former
director of the CIA denounces the
current president as a traitor the
Democratic presidential nominee condemns
most of her opponents supporters as
deplorable and indeed irredeemable
racists sexist sand bigots judge
Cavanaugh's nomination to the Supreme
Court is assailed at the last minute by
a series of accusers whose accusations
each more outrageous than the last paint
him as not only a deplorable sexist but
as an irredeemable sexual criminal these
incidents and many others like them warn
us not
of a breakdown in civility but if a
dangerous rupture in our civil fabric
now I imagine that many of you have been
waiting as eagerly as I have for the
publication of the paperback edition of
Hillary Clinton's recent book a title as
you know what happened I think there are
a few a couple of other words in the
middle between Wotton happened that her
editor must have snipped but your wait
is over the paperback is out and
includes a new after word in which she
as she evaluates the Trump presidency so
far alongside her plea for a return to
civility she writes a president Trump
rejects the rule of law and comes close
to being quote a tyrant plain and simple
unquote he wages war on truth and reason
denigrates the Free Press and undermines
national unity and civil rights through
his racist hate speech that's her term
hate speech and divisive policies thank
you for your civility Madam Secretary
but American politics has always been
rough and ready
what's revealing is that she doesn't
blame Trump for these transgressions
quote he is as much a symptom as a cause
she writes of these authoritarian
tendencies the true blame lies with
quote the increasing radicalism and
irresponsibility of the Republican party
including decades of demeaning
government demonizing Democrats and
debasing norms in other words it's the
GOP that gave us Donald Trump and the
GOP is the party guilty she says of
stealing a Supreme Court seat I hope we
get back that Supreme Court seat
and also working she says to
disenfranchise African Americans and
denying climate change she blames also a
small group of right-wing billionaires
who have helped to build she quote an
alternative reality where science is
denied lies masquerade as truth and
paranoia flourishes I don't mean to
quote so much that you'll be discouraged
from running out to buy the book but
here is one gripping sentence quote by
undermining the common factual framework
that allows a free people to deliberate
together and make the important
decisions of self-government the
Republicans opened the way for the
infection of Russian propaganda and
trumpian lies to take hold unquote in
the eyes of our liberal democratic
accusers we are all Trump Ian's now we
conservatives I mean and have been for
decades so Trump is not you know
anything special he's just a Republican
and believe me if Jeb Bush had won or
Marco Rubio had won the arguments would
be virtually the same any Republican
think back to george w bush HW Bush
Reagan the arguments against them had
the same tendency I will say that
Hillary is right about one thing
deliberation is the activity of
rationally choosing means to agreed upon
ends if we don't agree more or less on
our ends there's little possibility of
debating civilly about the means to
those ends what the Federalist Papers
called the quote the cool deliberate
sense of the community unquote cannot
emerge if there is no community sharing
fundamental ends and rationally
deliberating on them
six years ago I wrote a book about
Barack Obama in which I predicted that
modern liberalism under pressures both
fiscal and philosophical would either go
out of business
or be forced to radicalize if it chose
the latter I predicted it could rattle
it could radicalize along one or both of
two lines towards socialism and or
towards an increasingly postmodern that
is willful and nihilistic form of
leadership and representation actually
American liberalism is trying both
Bernie Sanders view of the world as you
know is ascendant the latest thing with
the youngest generation of Democratic
leaders is to embrace socialism openly
something that would have been
impossible and unheard of during the
Cold War but so in the ascendant is also
identity politics with its quasi
Nietzschean faith in race sex and power
as the keys to being and meaning in the
me2 movement for example we've heard a
lot of this in connection with justice
or judge Cavanaugh's nomination the
credo is always believe the woman
because she is a woman in in other words
truth will emerge not from an
adversarial process weighing evidence
and testimony before the bar of reason
but from yielding to the will of the
more politically correct her truth is
stronger than any objective or
disinterested truth but how can we have
a common factual framework in Hillary's
terms if the facts depend on values and
all values are relative and hence the
strongest values dictate the facts and
thus the truth
in the Claremont Review of Books the
journal I edit we have described our
current political scene as a cold Civil
War a cold Civil War is better than a
hot or shooting one but it is not a good
situation for a country to be in
underlying our cold Civil War I think is
the fact that America is torn
increasingly between two rival
constitutions two cultures two ways of
life political scientists sometimes
distinguish between normal politics and
regime politics normal politics take
place within a political and
constitutional order and concern means
not ends by contrast regime politics is
about who rules and for what ends or
principles it questions the nature of
the political system itself who has
rights who gets to vote and what do we
honor or revere together as a people
I fear America may be leaving the world
of normal politics and entering the
dangerous world of regime politics in
which our political loyalties diverge
more and more as they did in the 1850s
between two contrary visions of the
country one of these is based on what we
may call the original Constitution as
amended this is the Constitution
grounded in natural rights the
Constitution that was written and
ratified in 1787 and has been
transmitted to us with significant
changes some improvements and some not
but recognizable still as the original
Constitution to simplify matters we may
call this the conservatives Constitution
though conservatives have never agreed
perfectly on its meaning and many non
conservatives of course remain loyal to
it the other Constitution
is what first progressives and then
liberals for a hundred years now have
called candidly the living Constitution
this term the living Constitution
implies that the original one is dead or
at least on life support and that in
order to remain relevant to our national
life the written constitution must be
infused with new meaning and new ends
and therefore with new duties rights and
powers new administrative agencies new
mandates all overleaping any structural
limitations that the original
Constitution may have tried to put on
government as a doctrine the living
Constitution originated not in law
schools but in America's new departments
of political science and social science
in the late nineteenth century and it
was soon at the very forefront of
progressive politics it's always been
more than just a doctrine for judges it
was intended to offer a way towards hope
and change for all three branches of
government and eventually for American
society as a whole one of its prime
formulators Woodrow Wilson as a young
man had contemplated actually a series
of constitutional amendments to reform
American national governments into a
kind of parliamentary system which would
be able to bring faster change to
American politics but he quickly
realized that that plan amending the
Constitution was going nowhere
Plan B however was the living
Constitution while keeping the outward
forms of the old it would change uh
turley the spirits in which the
Constitution was understood the
resulting Constitution the Liberals
Constitution is not a constitution of
natural rights of individual human
rights
but of historical or evolutionary right
Wilson called the spirit of the old
arrangements Newtonian after Isaac
Newton and of the new ones he was
proffer Nguni n' after charles darwin
certainly one of the few times an
American president invoked Charles
Darwin as an authority and as a you know
a source of political reform by
Darwinian Wilson meant a constitution
that far from being unchanging or is
difficult to amend as possible would be
mutable amenable easily to
experimentation and adjustable to the
zeitgeist the late Walter burns had a
neat formula for this change
he said the point of the old
Constitution was to keep the times in
tune with the Constitution the purpose
of the new is to keep the Constitution
in tune with the times but until the
1960s or so most progressives and
American liberals expected the living
Constitution there's to replace the
original Constitution the Conservatives
gradually almost imperceptibly they
expected progress not revolution they
charted a kind of conservative slow
motion path to liberalism they were
evolutionists Darwinian x' remember then
something unexpected happened something
unexpected unexpected by the Liberals at
least what happened was the sixties in
which the so-called new left abandoned
evolution for revolution and partly in
response the defenders of the old
Constitution began not merely to fight
back to try to slow evolution down but
actually to call for a read
turn to the first principles of the
Constitution by seeking to revolve back
to the starting point they proved to be
Newtonian x' after all and also in a way
revolutionaries since the original
meaning of revolution is to return to
where you began as a celestial body
revolves in the heavens called by many
names in many connections the
conservatives who in the 1950s and
especially the 60s and 70s who began an
epic campaign against the inevitable
emergence of the living Constitution had
in common the desire and the felt duty
to oppose the gradual or the sudden
disappearance of limited government and
of republican virtue in our political
life when it became clear by the 1970s
and 80s that the Conservatives surrender
slow-motion surrender was off the cold
Civil War was on confronted by sharper
deeper and more compelling accounts of
the conservatives Constitution the
Liberals had to sharpen that is
radicalized their own alternative
following the paths paved by the new
left
so rather than converging the living
Constitution and the old conservative
one diverged and the the gap between
them became a gulf so today we are two
countries or we're on the road to
becoming two countries each constituted
differently consider a few of the
contrasts the prevailing liberal
doctrine of Rights traces individual
rights to membership in various groups
racial ethnic gender now class-based
groups
which are undergoing a continual process
of consciousness-raising and empowerment
this was already a prominent feature of
progressivism a hundred years ago though
the groups have changed since then
when Woodrow Wilson wrote his textbook
when he was a political scientist before
he ran for office he wrote a textbook
the first question in the textbook is
which races shall we study I'm not
making this up I mean can you imagine
you open the textbook the first question
which races shall we study and his
answer was it's it's simple its
straightforward will study the Aryan
race because the Aryan race is the one
that has mastered the world the
countries of Europe and the Anglophone
countries America Australia Canada and
so forth have conquered the world and
you know Africa Asia most of these
weren't colonized by European powers
they had the Europe Europe white
European civilization the Aryans had
science the arts armaments all the
advantages wealth on their side so from
from Wilson's point of view you've
studied the winning race the Aryans not
the losing races now he was not a he was
not a racist in the full sense of the
term because he expected the less
advanced races over time to catch up
with the Aryan race over a great deal of
time to catch up with the Aryan race you
know his version of politics is really
our version except the winning and the
losing sides have been switched and now
you know white supremacy white power is
the devil and in a way you know white
the white race European civilization
dead white males I mean you're familiar
with all these wonderful diminishment
they're the enemy and all the races that
were oppressed in the past are now in
the driver's seat they are they are the
races that need today compensation
privileges and power to make up for
their neglect in the past but the
analysis is the same it's just that the
who is on the top on the receiving end
and who's on the bottom have changed the
centrality of groups and the derivation
of your status as an individual from
your membership in a group hasn't
changed at all
today's on you know today's campuses
there is what they call the you know
identity politics and ID the
identitarian obsession which you can see
in affirmative action policy and in
other large stretches of American law
and mores and the basically the liberal
argument is the same but the as I say
the the winning and losing groups in
that argument have shifted now
conservatives to treasurer minority
rights but conservatives regard the
individual as the quintessential and
most endangered minority they trace
individual rights we trace if I may say
individual rights to human nature which
lacks a race a human being has no race
per se human being can be yellow red
black white be honest any color human
nature lacks a race other than the human
race and also lacks all ethnicity gender
or class and it's to the essence of an
individual as a human being
that conservatives trace their rights we
have rights because we're human beings
not because we're tall or short human
beings or white or yellow human beings
but because we are human beings with the
soul with a with reason and distinct
from other animals and from God
we're not beasts but we're not God we're
that in between being and conservatives
seek to vindicate this human equality
and liberty including majority rule
against the liberal constitutions
semi-feudal alternative where everything
is based on your group your race your
gender your class and so forth that's
how far liberals and conservatives are
apart from one another now how far the
two constitutions have diverged there's
a liberal First Amendment today and a
conservative First Amendment nowadays
liberals are very interested in turning
free speech into what they call equal
speech insuring that no one gets more
than his fair share of it the new
emphasis leads to trying to redistribute
speech rights via limits on campaign
contributions repealing Citizens United
and even amending the First Amendment to
narrow it in order to take speech rights
from those who have too many the rich
and give them to those who have too few
the poor and I remind you the official
position of the Democratic Party in its
platform in 2016 was to amend the First
Amendment to narrow the First Amendment
as you know there's a big difference
also between the original constitutions
freedom of religion and the competing
liberal constitutions freedom from
religion another glaring difference is
that the Liberals Constitution has no
second amendment
the living Constitution theirs is
designed to overcome that you've heard
this today if you were at the earlier
excellent panel preceding tonight's
dinner but the living Constitution is
designed to overcome separation of
powers and all other restrictions checks
and balances on the government's their
what they lust for is the is the ability
to coordinate concentrate and enhance
government power not to separate it
restrictive check it because this power
has flowed mainly through the hands of
unelected administrators and judges our
elected Congress finds itself
increasingly dispirited and unable to
legislate as the Financial Times put it
recently our Congress is a sausage
factory that has forgotten how to make
sausage how how is it possible to
resolve our cold Civil War without
turning it into something much worse
well I think there are probably five
paths forward one would be to change the
political subject you know Ronald Reagan
used to say that when the little green
men arrive
you know from outer space all of our
political differences will be
transcended and humanity will unite for
the first time in human history well I'm
here to tell you if that happens the
cold Civil War is off if some other
jarring event a big war or a huge
natural calamity happens that might also
reset our politics to that subject would
be changed but if we can't change the
subject then a second possibility would
be perhaps we could change our minds
that is maybe persuasion or some
combination of persuasion and moderation
would allow us to end or to endure a
continuing division of the sort we have
perhaps one party or side will persuade
a majority of the electorate to embrace
its constitution and thus one side will
win at the polling booth or in the
legislature now for generations
Republicans have longed for a realigning
election that would turn the GOP into
America's majority party and political
faith they're certainly possible it
looks I think unlikely only two
presidents in the twentieth century were
able to affect enduring changes in
American public opinion and voting
patterns Franklin Roosevelt and Ronald
Reagan
FDR inspired a political realignment
that lasted for a generation or so and
that lifted the Democratic Party to
majority status Ronald Reagan inspired a
realignment of public policy but wasn't
able to make the GOP into the majority
party since 1968 the norm has been
divided government in which the people
have more often preferred to split
control of the national government
between the Democrats and the
Republicans rather than to entrust it
entirely into the hands of one or the
other party this was never the pattern
in American history until the post 1968
period until 1968 the most of the time
not all the time but most of the time
Americans would entrust the Senate the
house and the presidency to the same
party in each election they would change
the party sometimes but still they would
vote for a party to run the government
that has not been the pattern for a long
time now since 1968 a long time ago
neither President Obama nor President
Trump so far has persuaded the American
electorate to embrace his party as their
natural representative worthy of
patriotic allegiance over a generation
or more now Trump of course is new to
this and his party in Congress
particularly is basically pre trumpian
he has not had a chance to change the
composition of the House and the Senate
very much he did not win the 2016
election despite what he might say by a
very large margin and he was not able to
bring in large numbers of new
Republicans into the house or the Senate
it's the Republican Party that you see
there is basically a pre trumpian party
nonetheless he has the opportunity now
to teach Republicans how and why to
fight like he does that is not to flinch
in the face of political correctness and
elite opinion from what I hear of the
Cavanaugh hearings today a few
Republican senators Lindsey Graham
apparently at last may be catching on
but the narrowness of trumps populism
which is not a word he uses by the way
to describe himself or his movement
means that he still needs some parts of
the pre-existing conservative coalition
or the conservative electoral base and
some parts of the conservative arguments
his populism is not enough he has to
reach out to the existing Republican
Party as he has done adopt some of its
agenda adopt its electoral supporters
but of course gradually change them
bring them around to America first
conservatism if he is to have any chance
of bringing off a future political
realignment
and I would have to say as a political
scientist that the odds remain against
him at this point if we can't change our
minds by winning over the other over the
Liberals there is still the possibility
maybe that we could moderate our
disagreements and learn to live with
them more or less permanently but to me
that too seems unlikely given the
embittered trajectory of the last two
decades so if we won't change our minds
and can't change the subject I think
there are only three other ways out of
the cold Civil War one might be a vastly
reinvigorated federalism one of the
reasons for constitutional federalism in
the first place was that the states had
a variety of interests and views that
clashed with one another and could not
be pursued in common if we had a reef
Laur ilysm some of the differences
between blue states and red states could
be handled discreetly
by the states themselves the disruptive
issues could be D nationalized but again
the problem is we have abandoned so much
of traditional federalism it's hard to
see how it could come to our rescue at
this late juncture economic and
technical or technological changes I
think appear at least to militate
against the solution to so my friends
that leaves two remaining possibilities
one alas is secession which is a danger
to any federal system James Madison
wrote about there's a great length in
the Federalist anytime you've got a
federal system you face a possibility
that some states will try to leave it
and I remember from my youth the
wonderful libertarian bumper sticker you
know libertarians are sort of Pro
secession and certainly some of them the
bumper sticker said
if at first you don't succeed try try
again but it is a possibility that Czech
Republic and Slovakia have gone their
separate ways
peacefully just within the last
generation but America is much better at
expansion and contraction and George
Washington's admonitions to preserve the
Union I think still maybe miraculously
somehow linger in our ears so secession
would be extremely difficult for many
reasons not the least of which is that
it could lead as we know from experience
to the fifth and worst possibility civil
war and not of the cold kind under
present circumstances American
constitutional the American
constitutional future seems to be
approaching some kind of crisis a crisis
of the two constitutions the timing and
exact dimensions of which remain obscure
let us pray that our countrymen will
find a way to reason together to
compromise our differences which will
allow us to avoid the worst of these
dire scenarios so ladies and gentlemen I
leave you with this thought
here's to the better angels of our
nature thank you very much
[Applause]
brought to you if this is 1859 is 1861
inevitable did you hear that question
okay the question was if this is 1859 is
1861 inevitable well in the first place
I don't think is 1859 it's earlier than
that but it no it's not inevitable I
mean I don't think anything in politics
is really inevitable in in that sense in
the sense of preordained if you believe
that human beings are free that is have
free will and reason to guide free will
you can't believe in any inevitability
in history because you just don't know
what they will do and that's my position
we don't know I'm my analysis only goes
this far that the trends are bad and
that the it used to be that Republicans
Democrats that they you know the old
Constitution the new Constitution agreed
on enough to have a kind of common
common Civic culture still we agree on
elections we agreed on civil rights we
agreed on sort of the dignity of
American history and the heroes of
American history more or less but I am I
am disturbed by the fact that those that
common ground is eroding I don't think
it's inevitable that it will continue to
erode much less to the point of civil
war but I think that that is the
direction of current events I mean you
know how how many you know how much ink
has been spilled
by the left in arguing that sir
president Trump is not a legitimate
president because he was not elected by
the popular majority how much was
spilled against george w bush after the
2000 election in the same vein elections
are less a you know a unifying event
than they used to be and secondly civil
rights the definition of civil rights is
beginning to slip away a common
definition of civil rights as i argued
is beginning to slip away and third the
common civic culture the common heroes
the common history is now radically
under assault by a left that has only in
the last generation turned against
America I mean FDR even LBJ certainly
Woodrow Wilson John F Kennedy
they were optimists about America they
believed in America
however you know liberal their
interpretation of America they for them
Lincoln was a hero Washington was a hero
and and the Union was a moral cause for
them but increasingly starting in the
universities the the left has made the
argument that it's not in fact just the
plutocrats the few that they opposed in
the American past and the American
present it's the many and so the
argument is not now that Americans you
know have been bamboozled by the rich
and dominated by the capitalists
although that argument is still heard
but the basic argument is America is a
sick country it's it's been racist
sexist homophobic xenophobic transphobic
etc from the very beginning and not just
the minority the majority the people
have been corrupt morally sick from the
very beginning it's very hard to find
common ground with that opinion
now it is true that even Hillary Clinton
and many other liberals are now calling
for a renewal of civic education in
America but the problem this is part of
their reaction against Trump they
believe you know Trump is betraying
America so they wants to sort of go back
to America and Obama was very much on
the same wavelength but the problem is
their America and our America are really
moving in opposite directions so what
would be the core of civic education
that's that's the problem over here
sorry speech I don't know exactly where
to begin because I go back to a
fundamental part that we seem to have
lost in our education and our common
knowledge about our founding there is a
common key between the Declaration and
the Constitution that we have lost life
liberty the pursuit of happiness which
has no color has no national boundary
and has no country except in the concept
of what it is and that's the foundation
for which our Constitution was begun and
unless we get that back I don't
understand how we come to a common
knowledge of who and what we are your
comment sir well I could did everyone
hear that I agree I couldn't agree with
you more Larry Ahrens written a very
good book about the relationship between
the Declaration and the Constitution
which I recommend to everyone if he's
not already stuffed a copy in your
knapsack you should read it I agree with
that and
you know President Obama might agree
with that too in his own way
yeah anymore I mean President Obama
despite his radical side is looking like
a moderate in the Democratic context the
context of the Democratic Party he's
criticized Hillary for having you know
said that half of trumps supporters are
deplorable and irredeemable racists and
sexist and so forth
now I'm sure he believes the same thing
I mean his remarks about clingers you
know to their guns and God and so forth
that point in the same direction but at
least he recognized that when he made
that remark that was a mistake
and he never made it again Hillary has
is doubling down on that so you know
from President Obama's point of view the
founding is defensible because the
founding enshrined only one real
self-evident truth and that was that
America is open to change and that's his
whole you know that's what he honors in
the founding that the founding allowed
us the ability to surpass it and
supplant it and to leave it behind and
to make a better America in which racism
has been at least partially overcome
because we could elect a black president
he doesn't want to write himself out of
history after all so he has to be proud
of that and even of the country that did
that that elected him but the idealism
of the that is expressed in your
statement that the ideals of the
Declaration inform the Constitution and
even the compromises with slavery and
the Constitution have to be seen in the
light of an anti-slavery principle
is there are some people on the left
fortunately who still believe that but I
think they are in the minority and in a
diminishing minority so college my
question is twofold touching on what you
were just discussing first is this
discussion going on in the left in the
Commonwealth clubs or it's not a
monolithic movement what are they
looking at with regard to the prospects
of a hot or cold Civil War and secondly
to younger generations who are watching
this sort of political combat and being
baptized in it is there any indication
there that in the longer run should
America move beyond this particular
moment of crisis that there can become a
new consensus thank you
well those are a good question so the
they were audible okay
if you talk to young people on campus as
I do if you teach young people you see
you know a new cohort every year
always younger they I've been surprised
in just the last two or three years how
quickly what was a radical view of
America a marginal marginalized sort of
view of America has become commonplace
in them and I didn't learn it in college
I picked it up in high school but now
students to my surprise talk about white
supremacy as though it were everyone you
know it was a fact of life that everyone
always knew about and had acknowledged
in fact the term was rare and certainly
not a you know the prevailing lens
through which to look at America and
American history but even conservative
students in my experience in Claremont
have learned that rhetoric I mean they
want to move beyond it they want to you
know pierce it but they haven't yet
learned how and so the whole
identitarian to use a horrible word
agenda this sort of comes with whites
with the notion of white supremacy the
charge of white supremacy is very
current among the the freshmen
sophomores juniors seniors that I teach
now this ought to in a way this is a
cause for pessimism but it's also in a
way a cause for optimism because it
shows you that if you get to them young
you can influence their thought you can
shape their thoughts and if they only
heard some arguments on the other side
they would be able to think their way
through this prejudice but the fact is
they apparently haven't heard many
arguments on the other side so they're
not I mean the young you know Nietzsche
says the young are always too angry
and to Reverend and that's true I think
but they want to learn and so we we need
to find a way to teach them we need to
find a way to get to them it's very
difficult though when the faculties
themselves are so biased ideologically
politically as as you all know one of
the great things about Hillsdale is
obviously that it's a bucking that trend
and in a big and noble way but it is
it's very difficult now on the but the
left as a whole I think is still torn on
this question and depending on how
things work out in the midterm elections
and how things work out in 2020 you know
the great thing about the American
political system is that it does there
are elections and it does reward and
punish certain politicians and certain
positions there was if you remember back
in the 1970s 1980s the Democratic
Leadership Council which was a movement
of centrist Democrats to take the party
back from McGovern and the sort of
extreme anti-vietnam left that had
seized seize power in the early 1970s
with with the nomination of McGovern in
1972 after McGovern you got Jimmy Carter
who was a much more centrist figure and
you God eventually Bill Clinton in the
1990s who had been president of the
Democratic Leadership Council something
like that is still possible but the
problem is we've moved farther left than
we were in 1972 and so the movement
would have to be well funded and in and
you know have a lot of grassroots as
well as the gumption to fight and right
now I don't see any sure signs of that
but it's possible and losing big enough
would be the incentive to make it
probable
yes sir I guess oh sorry your oh sorry
you've got a competitor right behind you
thank you for another exceptional
speaker and hello miss penny would you
could you describe a course of action to
counter what we're encountering now yes
well I think the I mean to look the best
thing happening in American politics
right now is Donald Trump I think I mean
he's not an I mean he he has some
limitations but I think fundamentally he
is on the side of the country he is
against the you know multicultural or
you might say the nihilistic left and
it's hatred of America I mean I think
what let's what making America great
again really means is it's it's a
challenge it's a it's a it's a a
challenge to fight for the center of
American politics I mean do we actually
believe that America was once great and
the left basically doesn't and so do we
want to make America great again
presumes that we were once great and
that we know why we were great and that
by perhaps following those or similar
policies we could be great again
and so he's appealing in a way to not
just Republicans or even self-proclaimed
conservatives but to a vast middle of
the country who still love America and
still one demerit to America to succeed
and he has the he had the insight though
not at all a politician or practiced or
you know groomed politician to
to make that appeal to make it bluntly
to make it powerfully and and I think
persuasively to a lot of Americans now
again he won you know by very narrow
constitutional majority and apparently
not by a popular majority but he won and
that's a very important datum and as
usual in such cases you can learn a lot
by studying the winning strategy and I
think that Trump is getting better his
rhetoric is getting better his speeches
are getting better
he still has a way to go but he began as
a complete amateur I mean you can't you
can't really overestimate how well how
much of an amateur he was I mean he
never stood for election for any office
anywhere
and so that's unusual in American
history I mean the presidency is not
usually an entry-level position but
things are things were so desperate that
a complete outsider was in a position to
to do the common-sense thing to make the
common sense appeal which none of the
other candidates much more sophisticated
much more politically experienced sort
of saw needed to be done and how to do
it
so I think we owe the president our
support and also our counsel in his
efforts to make America great again
which really means to make Americans
believe in America again
we have time for one more question Thank
You Jane you asked over already options
I think I'll be praying for a little
green men to arrive one hears more and
more today
indeed even on James Dobson recently
about the idea of an article five
convention of states which wasn't among
your options and I just wonder if you
would comment on what you think might be
the practicality but also the prudence
of that option
well it wasn't among my options because
I don't think it's a practical way
forward if you the problem with an
article five convention is you have to
have I mean you know which is a way of
you know to the states bypassing the
Congress in calling a convention to
propose amendments to the Constitution
those amendments then have to go back to
the states for three-quarters
ratification as in the conventional
process but the problem is you you who
will be the James Madison and the
Alexander Hamilton and the James Wilson
at the convention and besides that I
mean a way of saying the same thing
differently is the you don't want to
hold a convention unless you know what
you what amendments you want to come out
of it I mean you have to know why what
the ends are before you work for the
means to those ends and I looking at the
right
today there's great confusion about
what's really necessary and there's a
lot of attention on things like the
balanced budget amendment and so forth
which I think would be only very
marginally if at all helpful in this the
real problem is in the people it's in
the electorate and we have to rally that
we have to make we have to make the
argument why the Constitution is good
before we can move to the argument about
how to make it better and I don't think
that right now a convention to make the
Constitution better would really succeed
because the you know the major premise
has not been established in the hearts
and minds of the people solidly enough
so I'm I'm not necess
for that because it seems to me
imprudent and an unavailing right now
[Applause]